right now new developments in a murder
case that really shocked the valley good
evening to you thank you for joining us
at 5 i'm bryan loftis and i'm denise
valdez police say
22 year old leslie palacio was murdered
and her body dumped in the desert
now the coroner's office finally making
a ruling about her death and it's a
story our i-team has been following for
months
our david charns live in the newsroom
here at five with new details david
denise o'brien it sounds odd but the
coroner's office now officially ruling
leslie palacio's death
and cause a manner of death as
undetermined so that means there just
isn't enough evidence from what they
could see on her body
or what was in her system to determine
just how she died
the i-team first showing you what
prosecutors say is her accused killer
and his father
moving her body out of their east side
home last august her body was found
later near the valley of fire
prosecutors had said palacio's body had
been exposed to the elements for nearly
two weeks there
right now the palacio family continues
to plead for the man wanted for her
murder
to turn himself in we're never going to
see leslie ever again there's
nothing anybody can do in the world like
that would pay like see less again we're
never going to see her
hold her anything the bare minimum he
could do is turn himself in like he did
like
what they did during grand jury
proceedings a police officer describing
his interview with jose rangel
charged with helping his son moving
palacio's body
now he initially told police he had
thought palacio had died
in his home from an overdose that would
show up though in testing at the
coroner's office
right now erika rangala barrow remains
on the run the palacio family wanting
you to take a look
at your screen take a look at that photo
to find him right now he is believed to
be in mexico
the trial for his father jose starts in
just a couple of weeks
he has pleaded not guilty live in the
newsroom i'm david charns 8 news now